raiders veterans report on wednesday now
some of those vets are at las vegas
ballpark right now looking to help raise
some money in the battle for vegas
charities softball game raiders have won
both games and looking for number three
tonight don't forget they talk freshmen
well freshman out here at the ballpark
marshawn lynch into playing in this game
he's never played in it before logan
reaver at the ballpark he joins us live
hey in case you're running to marshawn
now logan did you bring some of those
skittles
i feel like i'm back in my element man
you know i i didn't i wasn't able to
bring the skittles but i got something
better i got my mental pyramid
you get the chain on that cost more than
my apartment
take me through i mean in this
environment and everything you got the
smile on your face would you like to be
here i mean just man just to be here in
general man if you look around you know
there's a lot of fans out here a lot of
people came out here to support and i
think that's what it's all about man
just support being out here you know
giving back to the community and just
having fun man that's what it's all
about how was the baseball game you were
talking about the glove fit where's the
game at top to bottom yeah i got it on
right now so the last time i played for
everybody out there watching the last
time i played was the third grade i'm
not a boat jacks or anything like that
but i'm an athlete
what is it like have you ever talked to
a hockey player before
uh no no are you are you ready all they
do is fight yeah i mean so i feel like
my trash i gotta get ready to fight but
we ought to hit a chariot event so i
don't think it's gonna be none of that
going on so who's got it down then the
football player or the hockey player
when it comes to the fighting game
don't lie now hey hey we're not gonna
start a brawl out here all right for
everybody watching at home we're not
selling a brawl out here
yeah i know what you mean how about for
the charity aspect just all in good fun
what does it mean to you man i just you
know come out here like i said you know
we're out here
showing up for the community right here
and right now it's all about fun and
games and you know we're just gonna go
out here have fun put on the show you
know for the community and you know
thank everybody afterwards absolutely
the man working up a sweat like it's
game day perryman that's all we got for
now here at uh the ballpark we'll send
it back to you chris all right thank you
very much logan more on the game tonight
at 11 o'clock home run derby coming up
at 6 30 bottom of the hour following of
course it's the game hard